hey guys how's it going I'm here with
Jenna today we are putting my matte
black mixer to work this is the first
time that I'm using it this is a limited
edition kitchena beautiful Artisan craft
this is should 212 out of 500 there's
only 500 of these so of course the first
thing that I'm going to make in this is
slime I don't remember ever using this
as a baking ingredient and also you
probably shouldn't try this at home
especially not with a very expensive
mixer that is cuz we don't know what's
going to happen I don't know I don't
know what's going to happen I don't
really know the recipe is they just said
glue and laundry detergent and that's
the two things that I have all right so
what do we do first first we dump in the
glue all of it well yeah that's why I
got all of the glue I thought maybe like
it was like an emergency glue slime
content is super popular on YouTube and
I found this out because of my dear
friends the Fine Brothers we did a
YouTuber's react to slime how do you
think you're going to react to this
slime what if you break your mixer don't
do that why are you getting it all over
the side this is supposed to be
organized sliming
oh that is a sound that's a
sound welled well formed well formed
turd
true oh boy tummy tickling oh
jeez no slime content oh no okay well
everything is a mess why are you using a
bread hook or a dough hook or whatever
it is that's a dough hook dough hook uh
because I don't know oh jeez oise all
right oh no I had glue in my hand and I
touched my hair all right I don't know
what the consistency of this is supposed
to be so I'm going to start mixing the
glue I'm going to start mixing the glue
I don't think I like this and this is a
dough hook we're making slime I'm going
to put this green in so that's why I
wore this nice shirt today I also packed
a green shirt glittery and gooey this
isn't mixing the way that I had hoped no
maybe I need more detergent what if it
splashes in our eyes we go blind do you
think there's something else that I'm
supposed to put in here maybe maybe I
speed it
up wao slime is sliming well we ran out
of glue maybe we add more
detergent I don't know how I feel about
this I don't know if I like this you've
slimed me this is why is it not green
okay what's it feel like it feels
absolutely like a big clunk of
mozzarella cheese okay well that's not
sure if this actually worked out the way
that it's supposed to maybe we got to
get in there with our hands you follow
Pinterest I followed nothing oh oh wow
like this is incredible I hate it though
I hate the touch of the feeling the
touch the feel of
slime the fabric of Our Lives oh I don't
like
it
it's I don't like this feeling I don't
want to touch it you can make it any
color you want it's too much do you want
to see how far it'll stretch no the
Slime to play with it's just a look at
Co why would you do that I don't know I
didn't god you're an idiot I wanted to
hit it now what do we do with the Slime
I don't know what to do with it this is
not as fun as I thought so we definitely
don't spike it like it feels disgusting
I absolutely don't like this you didn't
want to stretch it here stretch we
stretching the Slime is that what we're
doing so what do we do do we cut the
Slime and scissors well no so the in the
Instagram videos people they just get
like an overhead shot and then they like
do this they do that I haven't seen one
single slime video they call it
satisfying slime well I feel like
there's probably better recipes online
because this is not a recipe that I
think that you should follow basically
any recipe that I show you here it's
probably not something that you should
ever try to dup why does it look like
that I think I might have put too much
of of the laundry detergent maybe my
skin feels irritated I also feel like
maybe I shouldn't have used free and
gentle we need B we need locked up and
hard well guys thanks for watching if
you have a better slime recipe let me
know in the comments below and I'm I'm
definitely not going to make it I don't
think I ever want to do this again I'm
sorry for slapping your slime I just
didn't know what else to do with it
slime slap slime slap # should get a
slow mo slap she's like wiggle it
around the sound is even disgusting I
hate it I'm going to throw
up it's very I don't think I like this
all right guys thanks so much for
watching this was not exactly a slime
tastic that I had hoped for you stole my
word I apologize to the Slime community
of all of you slimers out there that I
have done you wrong this is not quite
the recipe that I was hoping for my B my
skin is burning I don't like it this is
not a good feeling like it just I'm
sticky I'm sticky so I'll see you guys
later I hope you have a slimy day if you
guys haven't seen the YouTubers react
video I'll also put that in the
description and you guys can check that
out where we react to slime videos I
don't like slime at all this was a
stupid idea I think your slime is just
this is broken this is broken slime yeah
but at least I put this really nice
beautiful limited edition matte black
KitchenAid mixer to work this is glue
and laundry detergent that's stupid and
now you're going to put something in
this bowl that's going to be edible is
anything that I put in this Bowl ever
edible in my kitchen it's probably safer
just to eat this glue don't eat the glue
don't eat the glue okay
bye
[Music]
no